>> TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME, SAD
ETSY BOYFRIENDS.
(APPLAUSE)
>> A MAN WILL GO TO GREAT
LENGTHS FOR LOVE. HE'LL SCALE
MOUNTAINS, WRITE SONNETTS, EVEN
GO TO WAR.
WELL, THE PINING FELLOWS OF
THE SAD ETSY BOYFRIENDS TUMBLR
ARE DOING MORE THAN THAT.
THEY'RE MODELING ADORAKABLE
CRAFTS ONLINE SO THEIR
GIRLFRIENDS WILL HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY FOR EUKELE LESSONS AND
IMPROV CLASSES.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A BEAU MADE
TO MODEL, AND FOR 250 POINTS,
YOU HAVE TO GIVE ME HIS INNER
MONOLOGUE.
FIRST ONE WHAT ABOUT THIS
COLOURFUL HUNK.
DANIEL?
>> I MURDERED MY GRANDMOTHER
FOR THIS SWEATER.
>> POINTS.
TOM.
>> HEY, I'M GREG AND I'M
PROOF THAT REGGIE WATSON'S
PERSONA DOESN'T WORK ON A
WHITE GUY.
>> YES.
THAT'S TOTALLY, YES.
POINTS.
>> THAT'S FUNNY BECAUSE I
WAS GOING SAY THERE'S
NOTHING SADDER THAN WHITE
COSBY.
>> YES, POINTS, I AGREE.
100 PERCENT POINTS.
>> ALL RIGHT. NEXT ONE.
THIS SINISTER LOOKING
MODEL.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF HE IS BEING
ATTACKED IN THIS PICTURE, OR IF
THAT JUST CRAWLED UP THERE AND
EXPIRED, TOM?
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS.
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS VIDEO,
I'M ALREADY DEAD.
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> SO WAIT A MINUTE.
SO HE DIES AND THEN THEY
SHOW THE VIDEO ON CHRISTMAS
MORNING?
ALL RIGHT. OPEN THAT LAST BOX.
>> Y'ALL KNOW ME. I SAID I
WOULD DO IT.
>> LAST ONE, THIS BEANIE-CLAD
BEARDO.
>> I'M KYLE KINANE AND I DIDN'T
EXPECT TO LIVE THIS LONG.
>> POINTS. DANIEL.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO NEED A
BIGGER VAGINA.
(APPLAUSE)